hey guys it's Justine and guess what we
are back with another unboxing today
we're unboxing the brand new MacBook Air
this is the gold version and if you're
new here I'm a huge fan of all of the
gold things that Apple has now oh just
matches so perfectly one of the main
highlights of the new MacBook Air is
that it now has a Retina display it also
has a touch ID an all new Butterfly
keyboard and force touch on the trackpad
you can spec this out to 16 gigs of ram
and a 1.5 terabyte solo stage arrives it
has 25% louder speakers it weighs just
2.75 pounds that's about a quarter pound
lighter than the previous air it's so
light that it just almost took flight I
actually was at Macworld when they
announced the original MacBook Air that
was in like 2008 maybe 7 2008 it's crazy
how quickly time is flying
speaking of blind let's cut this thing
open and take a look I can't wait to see
what this looks like okay when's the
MacBook Pro gonna come in gold because I
am so ready look at this what up
awesome oh so good doll it smells like a
fresh Mac eye comes in three colors it
comes with a Space Gray this gold and
the silver it's automatically turning on
oh boy come on
this is just what oh my goodness do you
see this
there's gold I need a moment so we've
got rose gold stickers well it's not
rose gold but this gold is like a it's
it's a nice gold let's see what else is
in the box we've got our USBC cable look
how small this little tiny charging
brick is like this gold is a really
beautiful color but if you want to
compare it to the gold of the iPhone and
the gold of the Apple watch it is very
very accurate and they look incredible
together like just take my word for it
if you don't want to take my word for it
I don't know who else is worth you're
gonna take
[Music]
so had the MacBook Air all set up I also
have my old MacBook Air this isn't the
original one this is the 2011 MacBook
Air definitely took a bit of a tumble
she wouldn't see right there I remember
when this happened it fell off of a
coffee shop table and it was so
traumatic everybody started freaking out
they thought that I was injured because
it was yelling so much around anyway the
MacBook Air is all set up this thing is
so beautiful and I'm also super excited
because I wanted to say a huge thank you
to all of you guys who entered the
giveaway that Jonathan and I did for our
iPhone 10 ours
it actually went so well that we decided
that we're going to do one more for
either a MacBook Air or an iPad pro all
you have to do is like and comment both
of our MacBook Air videos I'll put a
link of the description to his and be
sure that you are subscribed to my
channel and a Jonathan's channel and
whoever wins can choose from either the
iPad pro or the MacBook Air so stay
tuned for that I was super excited to
now MacBook Air let's chat a little bit
more about this thing because it is it's
so fast I actually brought it around
today we went on a little boat cruise
and Jenna and I both brought ours she's
making a video about the Space Gray one
so you may see the gold in a cameo in
her video as well
so right now jenna is shooting her video
about her MacBook Air but I wanted to
show you guys the color differences
between a Space Gray and the gold can
you believe it like so you have all
Space Gray I've got all the gold it
looks is so pretty it looks so great it
is weird
yeah which one do you guys like better
Oh leave us a comment which one do you
like below give it the colors look
amazing like this miss gray looks
playing I mean it looks basically just
like a squished down version of the
MacBook Pro the gold yeah your your boat
looks good gold doesn't just a scrape of
man once they release this gold phone
okay okay you go back to my video okay
this is something that I didn't buy
right away I held off until I couldn't
hold off anymore this is the Samsung x5
drive it is so fast you may be familiar
with those other little Samsung
solid-state drives that I've been
talking about forever but this is the
latest and the greatest
it's the Thunderbolt 3 USB C and it is
lightning fast so I've got a couple
projects on here this current
configuration of the MacBook Air is the
hundred twenty eight gig model so
anything that probably would require a
lot of space this is why I have an
external drive most of the videos that I
do edit I edit almost all off of an
external drive just because I never know
which computer I'm gonna be on I'm
always traveling and I do like to have a
backup with me at all times also one of
my first times really diving into Mojave
and the dark mode it's really great I'm
contemplating updating my macbook pro
now did you house my I'll cut them
working good that's usually my big
concern is updating my OS like I put
beta software on my iPhones all the time
I don't even think twice about it the
water comes to my macbook I'm always so
concerned about plugins not working
properly with Final Cut so we're gonna
open up and make a new project so this
is all shot in 4k I just copied this all
over so I've done absolutely nothing I
mean this is running super smooth I'm
actually shocked at how well this is
running like I'm not even joking like
I'm not saying that's just because oh
that's like something that I should say
I just automatically think if in a
smaller computer it's not gonna be able
to handle what I need it to do but let's
test it out I mean so far so good let's
add some color and just some things
okay that looks good that's all the
saturation to that let's go at I let see
color curves okay let's do a little this
it's doing what it's doing it says oh I
was actually just editing it yeah she's
still here
okay so it looks like it is possible to
edit so that's good
check one of the things I also wanted to
show you guys is over here this little
guy we need to we need to look and see
if what we've gotten here like look at
this this is for when I play dead space
oh do you remember so this is the 2011
MacBook Air let's see this is 1.6
gigahertz Intel Core 2 Duo 4 gigs of RAM
this is 1.6 gigahertz Intel Core i5 this
has 8 gigs of ram but it's still kind of
crazy that this one still is pretty much
working the butterfly keys are pretty
awesome I've enjoyed really typing on
them a lot and I love the new keyboard
layout on the MacBook Pro so now this
mimics that way more I love the touch ID
the speakers are pretty loud well like
let's you want to test it you test it we
first super-early lock try to catch
but I think my timing was pretty early
we've got an erroneous a vlog oh man
I enjoyed vlogging but we took it to a
whole new level I just want to show you
guys the MacBook Air really quickly and
this thing is pretty awesome I only got
to spend about a day with it so I do
want to keep testing it out further
before I give you guys any other updates
and some more thoughts on it so I will
be doing a follow-up video on this on
the Mac Mini and look for an iPad pro
video very very shortly and working on
something really fun so I look forward
to showing you guys that so in the
meantime let me know if you guys have
any questions about this about the Mac
Mini about anything about life I am here
for you know Jetta
people this me just talk about something
that is completely irrelevant to this
video
I love the Apple watch so much but I
think that I have a problem because the
competitions in this thing like it's
been getting super heated so the other
day I got short little stories is a
complete tangent I saw that our friend
Alex completed his his rings for the day
and it was a quarter until midnight and
I started freaking out because my rings
were not closed so I got out of bed what
and walked up and down my steps until I
met my goal and then I texted him and I
said I saw that you closed your rings so
I had to close mine and he said oh my
gosh I saw Jenna closed her rings so I
did jumping jacks we all have a problem
but I think that this whole concept of
the competition factor is it really is
amazing because it has been motivating
me to do more and I think it's a
motivating a lot of us so I would love
to hear from you guys like what do you
think is this something that you've been
using and if you're not I definitely
recommend it because it's so much fun
thank you for watching I am excited to
test this out I also kind of want to do
a video of what's on my 2012 MacBook Air
you see that was probably nothing not
interesting but oh man I back
like my or I chats and stuff remember I
chat oh no it's called iMessage it was
like okay really
no because okay I don't even think I had
his on here no it's called messages I
also just found my it was my 28 or 2006
or 2007 power book I gotta go
you do I gotta go okay this video is
over do my watch activate it didn't
cause it wasn't a real fall and I don't
have to fall activate setup I don't
think those kids I know
so this is crazy to about the Apple
watch the fall detect is automatically
on if you're 65 and over why am I on the
foot Parker what has happened
Oh also don't forget about our giveaway
go to Jonathan's channel TLD today
subscribe tell them that I said hello
you said hello and we look forward to
giving away iPhone 10 are and either an
iPad pro or MacBook Air so see you guys
later
this is the theme of the video
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]